[Musique]
quand on a dévoilé le nombre de millions
d'euros confié à l'état des cabinets
privés pour des missions qui des fois
n'aboutissaient à rien ça a rencontré
une colère des gens à ce moment-là sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat en groupe
est très engagé sur notamment la
question de l'utilisation de l'argent
public et puis sur les cabinets conseils
un jour on a vu apparaître dans une
réunion officielle à côté de Monsieur
Vérand qui était alors minis de la santé
un consultant d'un cabinet privé qui a
pris la parole en une place des
politiques et puis on est parti mais
vraiment dans une aventure et moi
aujourd'hui ça a encore de la résonance
j'avais rencontré des parlementaires qui
étaient ici au Sénat parlementaire
canadien et qui me dit qu'il
s'intéressait au sujet et qui sur la
base de nos travaux ici ont lancé une
commission d'enquête ça prend presque
une dimension internationale cette
affaire
je n'ai jamais eu envie d'être sénatrice
c'est le résultat d'un engagement en
fait très fort depuis l'âge de 14 ans au
Parti communiste français donc j'ai été
élu j'avais 44 ans ou 45 ans je sais
plus donc vous voyez ça a été un long
cheminement enfin fait de plein de
batailles de moments très actifs de
militant je suis une femme engagée de
conviction rentrer ici va attirée par
les dorures mais par la responsabilité
que ça a un combat que de d'être élu
sénatrice c'est-à-dire de porter à la
fois la population de mon département
mais aussi du pays et ce qui est bien
ici au Sénat c'est que le débat peut se
tenir quoi voilà je pense que mon groupe
est respecté mais on est quand même nous
aussi respectueux des autres alors on
respecte l'institution
si vraiment faire de la
Seine-Saint-Denis je suis né dans une
famille très modeste je suis moitié
algérienne moitié française on habitait
dans des cités populaires où il y avait
là encore à l'époque le sens de l'amitié
de la fraternité c'est une population
très attachante en tout cas que moi je
trouve très attachant c'est des luttes
aussi je n'imagine pas
vivre autre part et militer autre part
que dans ce département la seule fois où
j'ai quitté
la Seine-Saint-Denis pour des activités
professionnelles ou électives c'est
depuis que je suis sénatrice
[Musique]